you know me I am in your Friendship
Circle hidden in plain sight my clothes
are still impeccable but in the good
years when I was still making money to
look at me you would not know that my
electricity was cut off last week for
non-payment or that I meet the
eligibility requirements for food stamps
but if he paid attention you would see
that sadness in my eyes hear that hint
of fear in my otherwise self-assured
voice these days I'm buying that dollar
99 trial size jug of tide to make ends
meet I bet you didn't know laundry
detergent came in that size you invite
me to the same expensive restaurants the
two of us have always enjoyed but I
order mineral water now with a twist of
lemon not the $12 glass of chardonnay I
am full go in my menu choices meticulous
I count every penny in my head
Ida mirrored dividing the table bill
evenly the cover desserts and designer
coffees and second and third glasses of
wine I did not consume I am tired of
trying to fake appearances a friend told
me that I'm broke not poor and there is
a difference I live without cable my gym
membership and nail appointments I've
discovered I can do my own hair there is
no retirement savings no nest 8 i
exhausted that long ago
there is no expensive condo to draw
equity and no husband to back me up
months of slow pay and no pay have
decimated my credit bill collectors call
constantly reading verbatim from a
script before expressing polite sympathy
for my plight and then demanding payment
arrangements I can't possibly meet
friends wonder privately how someone so
well-educated could be an economic
freefall I'm still as talented as ever
and smart as a whip but work is sketchy
though mostly on
and all consulting gigs at 55 I've
learned how to fake cheeriness but
they're not many opportunities for work
anymore I don't remember exactly when it
stopped but I cannot deny now having
entered the uncertain world of formerly
and used to be I'm not sure anymore
where I belong
what I do know is that dozens of online
job applications seem to just disappear
into a black hole I'm wondering what is
to become of me so far my health has
held up but my body aches or is it my
spirit homeless women used to be
invisible to me but I appraised them now
with curious eyes wondering if their
story started like mine I wrote this
piece of year ago it's a composite of my
story and other women I know I wrote it
because I was tired of pretending I was
alright when I was and I was tired of
faking normal I wasn't seeing myself in
the popular press nobody I knew was
traveling the world or buying a condo in
Costa Rica very few of my friends had
set aside the 15 to 20 percent experts
tell us we need to maintain our standard
of living in retirement my friends many
in their 50s and 60s were looking at a
downward mobility a work for a life
proposition just a job loss medical
diagnosis or divorce away from
insolvency we may not have hit rock
bottom
but many of us saw a sequence of events
where rock bottom was possible for the
first time and the truth is it really
doesn't take much the median household
in the u.s. only has enough savings to
replace one month of income
47% of us cannot pull together four
hundred dollars to deal with an
emergency that's almost half of us a
major car repair and we're standing
on the abyss you wouldn't know it to
look around you I'm not the only one in
this situation there are people in this
room who are in the same predicament and
if it's not you it is your parents or
your sister or maybe your best friend we
get good at faking normal shame keeps a
silent and siloed when I first decided I
was going to come out with my story I
did a website and a friend noticed that
there were no photos of me it was all
kind of cartoons like this even as I was
coming out I was still hiding we live in
a world where success is defined by
income when you say that you have money
problems you are announcing pretty much
that you're a loser
when you're a graduate of Harvard
Business School as I am you're some kind
of double loser
we boomers hear a lot about how we have
underfunded our retirement how it's all
our fault
why on earth would we draw down our 401k
plan to cover the shortfall on our
mother-in-law's
North nursing home care or to pay for
our kids tuition or just to survive
we're accused of being poor planners and
deadbeats all that money we spent on
lattes and bottled water to shame and
blame is so deliciously tempting many of
us don't even wait for others to do it
were so busy doing it to ourselves
I say let's own our part we all could
have saved more I know I could have
saved more and if you were to rifle
through my life over the last thirty or
thirty years you would see more than one
dumb thing I have done financially I
can't change that now and neither can
you
but let's not mix up individual isolated
behavior with the systemic factors that
have caused a seven point seven trillion
dollar retirement income gap
millions of boomer age Americans did not
land here because of too many trips to
Starbucks we spent the last three
decades dealing with flat and falling
wages and disappearing pensions and
through the roof cost on housing and
health care and education it used to not
be like this we all remember the
three-legged retirement income stool and
which had the savings and pension and
Social Security
well that stool has gone wobbly take
savings what savings for many families
there's just nothing left to save after
the bills have been paid the pension leg
of the stool has also gone wobbly we can
remember when many people had pensions
today only 13% of American workers are
employed by companies that offer them so
what did we get instead we've got 401k
type plans and suddenly responsibility
for retirement planning got shifted from
our companies to us we got the reins but
we also got the risk and it turns out
that millions of us just aren't that
good and voluntarily investing over 40
years millions of us just aren't that
good at managing market risk and really
the numbers tell the story half of all
American households have no retirement
savings at all that would be zero no
401k no IRA not a dime
among 55 to 64 year olds who do have a
retirement count the value of that
median value of that count is a hundred
and four thousand dollars now a hundred
and four thousand dollars does sound
better than zero but as an annuity it
generates about three hundred dollars I
don't have to tell you that you can't
live on that with savings down pensions
becoming a relic of the past and 401k
plans failing millions of Americans many
niro retirees are dependent on Social
Security as their retirement plan but
here's the
Social Security was never supposed to be
the retirement plan it's not nearly
enough to best it replaces something
like 40% of your pre-retirement income
things have changed a lot from when
Social Security was introduced back in
1935 then a 21 year old male had a 50%
chance of living until he was 65 so he
retired at 60 did a little fishing
kissed his grandkids got his gold watch
he'd be dead within five years of
receiving benefits that's not the
pattern today if you're in your late 50s
and good health you're going to live
easily another 20 or 25 years that's a
really long time to make ends meet if
you are broke so what's the play if
you've landed here and you're 50 or 55
or 60 what's the play if you don't want
to land here and you're 22 or 32 here's
what I've learned from my own experience
the country is not coming there is no
big rescue no prince charming no big
bailout in the works they have a shot at
something other than being old and poor
in America we're going to have to save
ourselves and each other I've had to
come out of the shadows stand here
openly and I'm inviting you to do so as
well I'm not going to tell you that it's
not easy I ventured though to tell my
story because I thought it would make it
a little easier for people to tell
theirs I think it's only through our
strength in numbers that we can begin to
change the national law law conversation
that we are having on this retirement
crisis with so many of us shell-shocked
and adrift about what has happened to us
we're gonna have to build up from the
grassroots forming what I think I are
resilient circles these are
small groups of people coming together
to talk about what has happened to them
to share resources and information and
to begin to figure out a way forward I
believe from this base that we can find
our voices again and found the alarms
start pushing our institutions and
policy makers to go hard on this
retirement crisis with the urgency it
deserves in the meantime and there is an
in the meantime we're going to have to
adopt a live low to the ground mindset
drastically cutting back on our expenses
and I don't mean just living within our
means a lot of people are already doing
that what is called for now is to in a
much deeper way ask ourselves what it
really means to live a life that is not
defined by things I call it Smalling up
Smalling up is figuring out what you
really need to feel contented and
grounded I have a friend who drives
really beat-up raggedy cars but he will
scrimp and save fifteen thousand dollars
at one point to buy a flute because
music is what really matters to him he
small up I've had to also let go of
magical thinking this this idea that if
I just was patient enough and tighten my
belt that things would go back to normal
if I just sent in one more CD or applied
to one more job online or attended one
more networking event that surely I'd
get the kind of job I was used to having
surely things would return to normal the
truth is I'm not going back and neither
are you the normal that we knew is over
in this new place that were we are we're
going to be asked to do things that we
don't want to do we're going to be asked
to take assignments that we think are
beneath our
station and our talent and our skill I
have had to get off my throne last year
a good friend of mine asked me if I
would help her with some organization
work I assumed she met community
organizing along the lines of what
President Obama did in Chicago she meant
organizing somebody's closet I said I'm
not doing that she said get off your
throne money is green it's not easy
being part of the advance team that is
ushering in this new era of work and
living first is always hardest first is
before there are networks and pathways
and and role models before there are
policies and and ways to show us how to
go forward we're in the middle of a
seismic shift and we're going to have to
find bridge work to get us through
bridge work is what we do in the mean
time bridge work is what we do while
we're trying to figure out what is next
bridge work is also letting go of this
notion that our Worth and our value
depend on our income and our titles and
our jobs bridge work can look crazy or
cold depending on how you were rolling
when your personal financial crisis hit
I have friends with PhDs who are working
at the Container Store or driving uber
or lyft and then I have other friends
who are partnering with other boomers
and doing really cool entrepreneurial
ventures bridge work doesn't mean that
we don't want to build on our past
careers that we don't want meaningful
work we do bridge work is what we do in
the meantime while we're figuring out
what is next I've also learned to think
strategy not failure when I'm sort of
processing all these things that I don't
want to do and I say that that's an
approach that I would invite you to
consider as well so if you need to
move in with your brother to make ends
meet call him if you need to take in a
boarder to help you pay your mortgage or
pay your rent do it if you need to get
food stamps get the darn food stamps
AARP says only 1/3 of older adults who
are eligible actually get them do what
you need to do to go another round know
that there are millions of us come out
of the shadows cut back small up think
strategy not failure get off your throne
and find the bridge work to get you
through the lean times as a country we
have achieved longevity investing
billions of dollars in the diagnosis
treatment and management of disease it's
not enough to just live a long time we
want to live well we haven't invested
nearly as much in the physical infant
infrastructure to ensure that that
happens we need now a new way of
thinking about what it means to be old
in America and we need guidance and
ideas about how to live a richly
textured life on a much more modest
income so I am calling on change agents
and social entrepreneurs artists and
elders and impact investors I'm calling
on developers and disruptors of the
status quo we need you to help us
imagine the how to invest in the
services and products and infrastructure
that will support our dignity our
independence in our well-being in these
many many decades that we're going to
live my journey has taken me from a
place of fear and shame to one of
humility and understanding I'm ready
now to link shields with others to fight
this fight and I'm inviting you to join
me thank you
[Music]